a bulldozer demolishes the home of a
muslim politician and activist
authorities in the state of uttar
pradesh say mohammed javid didn't have
planning permission
two people involved in the violent
protests have been identified and it was
found they had illegal constructions and
bulldozers were brought in we will also
charge them under the national security
act
javid's family say he wasn't at the
protests and accused the governing bjp
of trying to intimidate them we've been
paying our house
tax
for around 20 years
and not once have we received any
information by any uh
development authorities or kalhabad that
our house is illegal or like you know
why were they taking even why were they
even taking our taxes if it was an
illegal house indeed
properties linked to muslim protesters
were also demolished on saturday
the demolitions followed days of
protests against two former bjp
officials who made remarks against the
prophet muhammad that many consider
offensive
protesters want one of them napo sharma
arrested for hate speech the party's
head of media in new delhi naveen kumar
jindal is also accused of making
insulting remarks
some protests turned violent on friday
but legal experts say authorities cannot
use that as a justification for
destroying people's homes you cannot
demolish a man's house for protesting
you cannot link it to the protests these
are two different things all together
so it is in my view it is in my view and
abuse of power
the bjp says it strongly denounces
insults against any religion sect or
ideology
but protesters don't believe that
statement and say these demolitions
speak louder than words
victoria gatenbee al jazeera